I might green used to Texas this is my
son Caleb debt nearly $300,000 between
business house little bit of everything
you got it yeah
I started to get into this I was about
26 years old single dad I was struggling
along fighting along we were making it
but not a whole lot not real well I
worked on a Ralph's and a mobile truck
so the radio on all day long and some
financial guy came on I think that's
listen to it it's like and it kind of
makes sense so figured I better get a
handle on the money situation because I
didn't have any of the time it was tough
I just worked with all I knew just go to
work that sets how this problem gets
solved I don't think these are clean I'm
trying to dig way out of idle we need to
find my way back to the top and that's
what the the common-sense approach which
is something that spoke to me helped me
do give me on the right way
whatever you is talking about me talk
about debt to me it was a maybe two
years ago he was like we're gonna try to
save up to pay off the house pay off the
truck and a whenever he pay off the
truck he would he would show me in it
was like a really big accomplishment for
him and it was pretty happy to see that
after I started this plan every tool I
sold I read next move I made was a step
toward the goal and it was you know I
couldn't wait to get to work I couldn't
wait to you know be infront of my
customer you know it just there wasn't
there was an in-game I don't know how
far away it was but I knew there was an
end and I was gonna get there so how
much have you paid off like three
hundred and seventy thousand dollars
whoa
how long did that take and five five and
a half years is that your house and
everything house business
everything Wow showing my mistake was
what was
Fortin showing him look this is this is
how this is how the world works now
everybody does it and this we thought
we're gonna do it I'm gonna be like the
exact moment just like you in the truck
and then you show me he showed me his
phone and he's like I'm about to pay
this house off and they eat ubuntu Sinan
he was
that's how spit off now and he was
really cool to see that well I I know it
was like for me growing up with little
education on money and you know put it
on a credit card then you can deal with
it he has a chance now to go through
life and leaving a discussant wolf even
a house yeah even a house they can be
done they've been that hard you want to
work for living off of a little really
help those emergencies and having pay
things often whenever I get older I will
pull in his footsteps I usually do the
dishes every day so that's obviously
stacking up really quickly and take out
the trash and uh it becomes a
negotiation fee that's like we're at a
flea market fighting about how much it's
gonna cost you know you could get down
to 75 cents you know to the point you
know it's like I'm not paying you worn a
dollar 25 for that and eight dollars for
this and see okay you know what I'll go
do it was a long run to the finish but
it was it was again and going to work
every day I'm going to work if I'm
getting rid of this this is this is my
goal this is how is this is how it's
gonna end
all right Mike and Caleb Houston Texas
three hundred and seventy thousand
dollars paid off in five years count it
down let's hear a great debt free scream
one two three
that was amazing feeling I can't even
describe what I feel just you looked
around
no one has any rights over it it's fine
if you can't see the end then you're
just you're spinning in circles you're
barely treading water and it's easy to
just stop see this out tread and just go
under just keep going keep treading
water but have a goal